The intoxicating effects of alcohol are a
combination of the genes that influence pharmacokinetics,
or the metabolism of. And the pharmacodynamics,
the target effects of alcohol. Although, alcohol dehydrogenase
is important in the first step of
alcohol metabolism. The second step, the conversion of
acetaldehyde to acetic acid by the enzyme
acetaldehyde dehydrogenase two, is actually the slowest step.
As the ethanol is broken down by ADH into acetaldehyde, more and more of
the acetaldehyde saturates the ALDH2 enzyme. It
gets busy. Its trying to actually metabolize
all of this acetaldehyde that's building up. But now, it's saturated. And the
bad news is that acetaldehyde is about ten to 30 times more toxic than alcohol.
Alcohol is intoxicating, and has the effects we've
talked about so far. But it can also
be bad for your body, if you have too much of it. But acetaldehyde is the really
bad stuff. In fact, the effects of alcohol flush reaction are due significantly
to the build-up of acetaldehyde rather than any build-up in alcohol. So
let's say you had reduced activity of ALDH2. Would
you expect your alcohol flush reaction to be more severe or less severe?